why do you need any assault rifles an
assault rifle is different than a gun I
want to go through here a couple of
things what the media got wrong about
the Sutherland spring shooting now that
the dust is kind of settle the question
of the day have you found it
increasingly hard to get a straight
story on this I found this to be the
case progressively with each shooting
but particularly this last one and I
don't just mean like online fake news
and clickbait sites but even from
mainstream outlets with updates that you
know we've tried to give you the radio
silence you see from CNN and some of
these mainstream outlets is odd to me
it's definitely have you noticed that I
don't know maybe I'm getting to this
point where I'm paranoid
but to leave this off I've discussed
this I think that the the firearm
argument in this country the Second
Amendment argument that's taking place
is it occurred between two parties gun
owners and they're completely uninformed
for evidence of that role MSNBC clip I
should check but you can buy a gun well
that's the root of the argument for why
we need to start talking repealing the
the Second Amendment because so long as
you have a constitutional right to it
the the number of laws that you can pass
to prevent people like like yesterday's
shooter from acquiring weapons is going
to be limited and I said this earlier it
should not be easier to get a gun than
it is to get a beauticians license it
should not be easier to get a gun than
it is to get a driver's license this is
a potentially deadly weapon right
because a 16 year old texting behind the
wheel of a Chevy Suburban isn't that's
first car I learned to drive by the way
Chevy Chevy excited killed a lot of
people yeah tons of steel glass and
gasoline behind you yeah to get a
firearm you have to have a state-issued
ID usually two driver's license either
way you have to go through the process
so he's wrong two times here yeah you
have to go through the process to get a
state ID and then use that to then go
through the background check when you
purchase a firearm anyone who has
purchased a firearm knows this is false
yeah but at least he's being honest now
just saying we should repeal the Second
Amendment yeah yeah he's come down to
the actual point that they want they
live in a fantasy world that none of us
can live in where guns don't exist and
that's sorry that's not what happens
well because none of these know the laws
they propose would have stopped any of
these shootings they know that I'm the
only thing that would stop it and their
eyes would be a
fleet repeal of the second amendment and
then there's this other little nugget
why do you need any assault rifles an
assault rifle is different than a gun an
assault rifle is different than a gun do
tell okay so this is just again
uninformed and firearm owners but here's
some claims that they made the media has
made that Rivera that's verifiably false
so one of the claims that we saw I think
it was CNN reported that the shooter was
Sam Hyde
roll the clip then we'll provide context
do you know anything about the attacker
we don't it was reported to me that he's
actually not from this community
apparently his name was released to Sam
hide that was the name I was it's a
classic 4chan meme it's a joke about
every shooting they put it out Sam its
troll bait oh no and the media is
consistently bamboozled for everything
on CNN Synod our Studios no access to
Google they're like the burgermeister
meisterburger when Kris Kringle
keeps bringing in toys just check the
stockings your Democrat representative
good on you voters another claim that
the shooter purchased the weapon through
the domestic violence loophole oh good
lord this is a new fictitious loophole I
don't have a chip to process this
sometimes where I'm like I don't know
how to process in any other way than
reductive laws preventing people Casey
didn't know people with domestic
violence charges from purchasing
firearms that's been there for a long in
the gut the employees just think they
failed to log the info on the shooter
and the domestic violence loophole but
what do you what do you mean by well he
broke the law he shouldn't have been
able to be broke a lot that's not that's
the Lulu vote also you know what else he
got through the loophole his domestic
violence
bridging the law is not a loophole so
there's a there's the rape in the alley
loophole there's a Kevin Spacey touched
a little boy when parents are looking
loophole what do you just did it anyway
he did he raped someone in an alley
I just can't fix stupid how do they just
take anything good thing is now they've
overreach so you know the gun show
loophole is a joke yeah it's the new
Costas you're they got to get that
loophole closed because it was a fix out
they'll go be personal loophole I've
read this and my brain froze for about
five seconds it's nobody but nobody
believes it there's a domestic violence
loophole like if you were to read the
law there's a law on the books like
section 1a those who commit domestic
violence shall not purchase firearms
section 1 B sub clause except there he
beat his wife over a casserole I just
read this I'm like I have really had a
moment where I'm thinking and I just
release do you question your own sanity
domestic violence loophole anyway it's
been all over the news yeah news okay so
another one that they use was that they
couldn't get a shooter use an evil
assault rifle right but the good guy
with the gun used a hunting rifle now
this comes from place slate said Kelly
used an assault rifle in his church
massacre the weapon used by Williford
has been described merely as a rifle
merely which suggests a hunting or sport
rifle rather than an assault weapon
incorrect phrases so embarrassing they
don't even know first off they're wrong
in their claim and then they're wrong in
their suggestion from the claim now
Wilford we had the exclusive interview
with him an extended interview can watch
on on our Channel he was the good guy
with a gun he used an ar-15 the same
kind of firearms Larry you always want
to ban a sporting and hunting firearm is
I know weird steven is quite proficient
with yes it was not good Jared so he
knocked it out and by the way it's late
did retract this only after being called
on it by uh I think Robbie know it
conservative review so they issued a
retraction but
I just don't how do you get it that
wrong yeah here's a leads into another
Clement you've seen they've claimed that
his hair his heroism Wilfred didn't
accomplish anything because the shooting
was already over so this is something
here's why they do this because the
whole good guy with a gun narrative the
left has been saying that's not really
true what do you think your your Rambo
you think you'll run you think you'll
save anyone with your gun they they've
tried to claim that it doesn't exist
here's a picture perfect scenario of a
good guy a borderline Saint a man who
looks like Santa Claus who rides
Harley's for underprivileged children
using an ar-15 saving lives and they
want to brush it under the rug so no
there's nothing to see here here's
something that they they they don't
report okay first off you wanted to say
something
Gerald was gonna say that yeah you see
that and then you see the little subset
that says and if prayers would have
helped they were praying in church you
see that little anti Christianity thing
right on top of that yeah they don't
want out they don't acknowledge that
this guy was a good guy with a gun that
they're scared of or that Christians
have any kind of bearing on this country
oh yeah I was so it's a guy went in and
he shot up a church yeah and right and
they're like all traitors thoughts and
prayers that way if prayers would have
helped like it's not true it's a cliche
yeah you know the whole thoughts and
prayers thing I think it's something
that people say like in French they just
always say Mike my condolences this is
the main thing that they say when
someone dies right okay you have to say
it
that being said just don't attack the
people who say but they said this
wouldn't have stopped anything because
the shooting had already occurred now
here's the truth the shooter was
actually walking around making sure that
people were dead finishing them off
execution-style and Wilfred interrupted
the one survivor actually told the story
but how the killer stopped right over
her and was about to shoe but was drawn
away by Wilfred now Wilfred also on our
show said that allegedly there were more
guns and ammo in the shooters car
that's not exactly get the hell out of
Dodge mobile now we can't confirm that
but that's what's so remarkable about
this story it's almost impossible to
confirm anything we had Steven Wilfred
on the show we just so happened his
daughter's a fan yeah um and he was
giving us information and I'm go how was
nobody else picking up on this well I
think I think you nailed the beginning
of this segment that it was proactive
misinformation because this I have
really you look through this thing and I
don't how anybody any pro gun control
advocates can look at this honestly and
say this is a good
for them this is their worst nightmare
Stephen wolf artist is their worst
nightmare to show up yeah and save the
day because it just disproves so much
yeah it is the good guy that got it is
Sal example the good guy with it's a
good guy with the guy eat the most
exactly and that's that's gone or a good
guy so white man what you've been told
right well wrap this what you have been
told is that a man legally purchased an
assault rifle which is different from a
gun legally purchased an assault rifle
and killed a bunch of people in a church
and died from self-inflicted wounds and
there was some other guy were a navy a
hunting rifle who helped speed it along
but oh my god there's no gun here's the
truth okay a man hurt any person by the
way through the domestic fire the truth
is a man illegally purchased firearms he
had no business procuring those firearms
in the first place he shot up a church
full of Christians likely motivated by
militant atheism and he was taken out by
a good Christian with an ar-15
quote-unquote assault rifle which isn't
like a gun that's exactly what happened
here in nra certified instructor Minds
you was the one who saved who knows how
many innocent lives and that's one thing
to when we talk about this we always
talk about gun crime you are at least if
you take the highest gun crime stat
including suicide including accidental
deaths including gang violence if you
take that number and you compare it with
the minimum number of lives saved by
firearms which is at least five hundred
thousand to three million we've covered
on the site a bunch of times you're at
least 16 times more likely to be saved
by a firearm as a lawful citizen then
killed by one it's it's up to 60
depending because it's really hard to
know how many times someone's life gets
saved by a gun often it's just pulled
out and that person's life is saved here
we have an example of someone
potentially saving dozens of lives we
certainly know that he stopped an active
shooter and the media covers at zero
they pivot to gun control specifically
regarding the gun that this guy used to
stop an active shooter I guess you can
make it work if you use the domestic
violence
it's your stupidity loophole let's work
on that loophole
hey did you like this video of course
you did
let's there's something wrong with you
in which case you can comment below
what's your problem with this video we
want to hear from you and we promise you
100% I give you my word as my bond will
answer every single negative comment for
those who are normal you can leave a
thumbs up and subscribe